hello reject nation the name's James
Bond James Bond
a leader of a margarita name that movie
people
he doesn't say give me a beer I know I
didn't realize we were fully committing
to the movie I won't name that's all
right John I Love You Man I love you too
man
yeah who's naming this okay waiting to
happen no time to die Bond film hey
YouTube this video is made for adults
all the movie studios that don't let you
monetize universally happen so make sure
to download and follow us on the
Stardust app people over there 30 second
reaction reviews for any film TV show
and/or trailer we post daily we're
posting a lot a little too much if you
ask me or not enough you decide it's
completely free to download to use so
check us out on there today let's watch
this
back
Hey
I mean faster than you can sponsor
and all the work shot of lunch
that's cool
James oh not as much confidence to you
[Music]
interesting really is a culmination with
[Music]
inspector Oh like Easy's gonna do a
thing i loving it great stunt work in
this trailer man
oh that's cool
never let bond take vacations it'll only
result in him having to come out of
retirement have we learned nothing oh
that's great yeah awesome I didn't have
you seen true detective or maniac I've
seen bits and pieces yeah that counts
that counts there's a plan man I watched
the first season a true detective I
think for the first time last year and
washed a lot of it over your shoulder I
think for the first time laughing yeah
there was some I've seen it some a
maniac cary fukunaga is direction here
looks like he's doing his thing for the
most part kind of like those menacing
tones those unsettling moments that you
see in this trailer I'm excited for that
because you know you got Blofeld in here
you got Remy Malick as a new villain who
kind of feels like he could be Blofeld
son also with that classic like crazy
mask in like a facial you know yeah it
seems like that whatever like creepy
things or whatever uncomfortable
elements that carry Fukunaga can bring
to his worth seems like they're letting
him do that to bring that level of
Menace to enhance the villainous threat
here because feels very personal to
every other Daniel Craig movies awesome
you know you had Casino Royale and then
these Skyfall I thought was great I'm
not a fan of Quantum of Solace even
though the actually the opening chasing
kind of reminds me of the hello Kali it
wasn't a big fan of Spectre but I
respect that they are still not they're
not trying to ignore Spectre I mean yeah
I got Blofeld back you got the girl from
the last Bond movie back which is rather
unusual for the Bond girl to come back
that's I don't recall the last time that
happened oh if it did it's a very rare
occurrence for that quantum was a direct
sequel but did it have much carryover in
terms of character
well definitely I mean yeah they maybe
figure we got Felix back in here you
know Q and Moneypenny back you got the
the usual play but for the Bond girl to
come back that's a rare thing and it
seems like she's actually very integral
to the plot here in terms of charging
him as a character because I like the
idea the concept Spector had left off on
he's selling off in the sunset
with I think the character's name is
Madalyn I sign it off in the sense of
Madeleine and then the other bought
movies were he's like yeah I'm retired
whatever he's by himself and this time
he's actually getting to live the life
he desired with uh with a woman he's in
love with gave it all up for her then
being pulled out of retirement form it
looks like from Felix having to go into
this adventure
I bet he's excited about that he's
really always happy he always happy to
be doing these missions and to be saying
his name it's like that seems like it's
got a splice of Casino Royale and
Skyfall blended into one but of course
factoring all the elements from all the
other Daniel Craig movies so this looks
like a fitting send-off for Daniel
Craig's James Bond I just love the dark
tones to it but the same time it still
feels bond you know yeah I mean this
feels like an amalgamation of all the
Daniel Craig bonds that came before it
to my eye anyway just you know kind of
looking at all the different images here
and I do like that it seems like Cary
Fukunaga is able to bring at least that
certain sense of like haunting grit like
it's it's weird it's like even the stuff
that he does that isn't full on genre
has a sort of percolating dread to
underneath the surface and this does
look like a very menacing Bond movie and
you also have some of the gadgets and
stuff you know you've got the headlights
that popped out the car and the machine
guns that come out and I know that one
of the big things that Spectre tried to
do and was wobbly on was mixing in some
of the older or gadget oriented
tendencies of Bond and the more you know
debonair you know like globe-trotting
aspects of bond with the more gritty
updated version and it seems like they
maybe have found a way to at least
smooth the gadgetry into this particular
plot and it also looks like they're
operating in a bit of a it almost
reminded me a little of like a Mission
Impossible
in the sense that like the team doesn't
look like they're operating up out of
their full
you know facility or whatever franchises
that succeed are always influencing one
or not yeah this is really tangible like
I you know there are obviously gonna be
big effects and set pieces but this
looked like a tangible bond
well it's good I think a lot has to do
with the fact of how it seems like most
of the action is in camera especially
the crazy stunts that they're doing
within the vehicles within the
bungee-jumping
and then even
the bike scenes and stuff that all looks
like real stuntmen are actually doing
this work which always just makes for a
refreshing piece of cinema and these big
action movies especially you know
nowadays where one of our most popular
spy franchises is actually enjoy but
it's so fake oh really
and leshawna Lynch okay so this is what
the bond rumors have been about about
her taking over double-oh-seven because
I haven't really been following the Bond
news the double-oh-seven
title has been passed on to her while
bond is in retirement and looks like
they're probably gonna team up in the
beginning it's either gonna be she gets
killed off in this movie and then he
takes up the double-oh-seven mantle
because it seeming like he's not really
gonna be double O's he's obviously gonna
be James Bond it's not gonna be
double-oh-seven in this movie at least
in the beginning I mean there are also
other tillow agents so I don't know if
they're gonna bring back that piece of
lore gonna let Bond be double-oh-seven
its bond well yeah and then I'm you off
with Shauna specifically specifiers ee7
I know they said you're a double oh but
I couldn't ruin cuz you know like we had
double of six in Goldeneye and stuff
like that like we've had other double O
agent oh I just the way the trailer
translated to me was that she took over
the double-oh-seven mantle retirement
yeah can someone clarify think of
basketball number where it's like you
just get yours or if you're just that
good they retire it or can there's like
this epic scope of a trailer like let's
go ball the information and one thing I
liked at least the vague glimpse of
their chemistry together and the fact
that he has like another agent who you
know has at least yeah reach that
double-o status to play off of
and I Rabi Malick gets a lot of chances
to shine in this movie this type of
villain porch rail at least in the way
the trailers communicating it to me
they'll probably come in pretty late
into the film a little bit more akin to
Javier Bardem in sky and then I got a
lot of that factors the way is the
makeup is done in his face feminine vibe
to yeah it's open like maybe there will
be another leg it's slightly homoerotic
edge to this bond but again what makes
this feel more personal is a lot of the
looks daniel craig is giving in this
trailer there seems to be a lot of pain
in his performance yeah and not because
he doesn't Daniel Craig doesn't there's
there's a lot of like harrowing emotion
that's being communicated in these shots
through his eyes make it just feel that
much more intense not just brooding and
angry yes kind of a sadness that seems
to be coming in his performance yeah and
you haven't you know sadness no yeah I
don't want to be involved yeah well yeah
he looks a little kind of thinned out
and yeah like he is really not
distraught but yeah it looks like bond
has some very emotional core to sure
yeah here yeah and I also just like that
there's some beautiful images that did
remind me even though we've been talking
about how much it's cool to see Cary
Fukunaga apparently getting to put his
spin it also does look like it matches
and some of these just beautiful shots
of reflections or lights and water and
those more luxurious visual aspects of
bond that you know add to the world
along with a dusty you know exotic
vacations and stuff like that
alright guys well as you see this
trailer for no time to die hope you did
if you made it to this point in the
video you guys can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell get
notified never got a YouTube video up
make sure to download and follow us on
that Stardust app tell us in the
comments what did you think of this bond
trailer do you think it will outdo
Spectre do you think it'll be the best
one in the franchise comment below what
are you excited about aim for wrap this
up I want to give a patron the day shout
out to a man named Luke Anderson the
most international man of mystery we are
now in the month of December Luke
haven't heard from you all year shout
you out every month you did it you did
it you manage to stay pledged this whole
time without ever talking to us capture
card on file without realizing you are
the best Christmas gift
could have asked for now up your pledged
that double-o status he doesn't watch
the one double okay he doesn't watch
this message is going out into the
satellites alright I won't try and come
up with a pun we could just say his name
and sit for five minutes and it all
suffice for him Luke it's hard to give
you personal shoutouts when I got
nothing to go off of with you buddy
you've that's okay keep it up for the
next year alright